Okay, like crafts and kids and shit is fun,
but like life is fun too. I just say life in general is better.
It's like Rocky and hard at first,
but it's kind of exciting cause it's yours
and you get to like make all the decisions and stuff.
And that's also kind of scary at first too,
cause you're like, oh my god,
I haven't had to make a decision.
Somebody has just told me what to buy for 10 years,
17 years. Well,
but I don't know, it's so much better.
Because here's what sucks.
You go from being like someone's daughter,
so you have your dad who's always telling you what to do,
whether he's nicer, you know what I mean?
Like I didn't have a shitty relationship with my dad,
had a pretty good relationship with my dad.
And you go from like your parents house to then the
your husband.
You just always have somebody like in your shit and it's annoying.
And I didn't even go from one to the other.
Like I did go to college and I had a little bit of life experience.
I think that's what made it even worse.
I had a taste of freedom. I had my rum Springer.
I went and experienced life,
not like this is fucking fun.
And then I was like, okay,
I gotta do the responsible thing
and settle down and get married and have kids.
And then I did. And then I Was like,
so all that fun shit stops,
like, I don't get to do that anymore,
huh?
Okay, like,
crafts and kids and shit is fun,
but like, life is fun too.
All that other stuff is fun too,
because you get to a point where you've like,
made all the new recipes you're gonna make,
you've baked all the fucking bread,
you've done all the fucking crafts.
Especially we start having like,
multiple kids,
we've been to the library programs,
I've seen the birds, I've seen the rockets,
we've built the solar microwave ovens,
and you're like, is this really life?
It's been 10 years of this.
Is this life?
And then it's wild, cause as your kids start to grow
and you start to see that they're starting to have these experiences,
you. There is a feeling of like,
why did my life have to stop just because they're started?
That doesn't seem,
ah, just doesn't seem right.
It doesn't sit right in my soul.
So I don't know. Five years after divorce,
I, uh.
10 out of 10, highly recommend.